- All right, welcome back!
I don't know about you, but
I find it highly unlikely
that we're the only intelligent
life in the universe.
I mean, it's just
egocentric to think that.
Like, it's like, come on.
But if you do, great,
you can believe in whatever you want.
(audience laugh)
And it's a conversation
that's come up often with guests here.
So who's a believer in aliens?
Anybody who believe in aliens?
(crowd cheers loudly)
Who is not a believer in aliens?
You just said, "Me, me, me, me."
Okay, so y'all are
wrong, but I don't know.
Find out though, in this little mashup.
Do you believe in UFOs or aliens?
- Absolutely.
- Okay. I believe that
anything could exist.
I don't know.
- Whoa. These come from outer space.
They have big, black eyes.
- Aliens.
I think there's gotta be aliens.
I just think it's not what we think it is.
- Yeah. I don't-
- I think there's other
life forms, but it's not
gonna be like what we-
- I agree.
You know, like in the movies.
- And there's absolutely other life forms.
- If aliens came during COVID,
and if the first place they visited,
was your studio during a recording-
- Yeah.
- They would think you're the
three dimensional overlord
over two dimensional people.
(audience laugh)
- Couple times, you know, throughout life.
I've seen some crazy stuff.
And some of it, I'm sure, most
of it's probably explainable,
but some of it, I like to believe-
- [Billy] Aye! I took that picture!
- [Kelly] He said, "Aye!"
(Kelly laughs)
- [Lisa] Ah. Wow.
- [Billy] I remember that thing.
I remember that one right
there. That's a beauty.
I took that.
- Do you believe, Lisa,
in extraterrestrials?
- [Lisa] I do. I do.
- [Kelly] I don't think
it's what we think it is-
- I know.
- But I do believe in other life.
- I think that just, we
can't be the only life.
- [Kelly] I think that's so
egocentric to think that.
- I think so too.
- [Kelly] Right? I mean,
unless you don't believe in it
and then I think that's fine, Rainn.
- [Rainn] No, no. Oh, I totally believe
that there's aliens, and some kind of,
they'd be traveling and
they'd be observing us.
And right now, I think those aliens
are looking down on
Planet Earth and going-
- [Lisa] Yes.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Kelly] Have you seen an alien?
Have you ever had an experience?
- This is gonna sound so out
there, but just bear with me.
So, I woke up in my room
and there was three beings,
and then-
- No.
They were like, do you
wanna see your planet?
And I was like, (beep) oh, sorry. Sorry.
- You were like, hell yeah.
- I was like, hell yeah, let's go.
So, I whooshed out of my room,
and was hovering over the planet.
And then all of a sudden they were like,
you wanna see our planet?
And I was like,
hell yeah.
- [Kelly] Hell, yes.
(audience laugh)
- I was totally for it.
You know what I'm saying?
- You said, hell yes.
(both laugh)
So, I can't call it like an abduction.
I called it an astral
projection for a long time,
'cause I went somewhere else.
- Yeah.
But then I realized maybe this was just
an encounter that I had.
- [Kelly] If an alien came down,
where would you show them
first, on Planet Earth?
What would you think would
be the best representation
of humanity?
- No, I'd probably take an
alien to an English soccer game.
- [Kelly] Really?
- Yeah, because all of humanity is there.
You have people-
- [Kelly] You have passion.
- Being enthusiastic.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You have great athletes
showing their athleticism.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- You also have some knuckleheads
doing some crazy stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I think that's a-
- That's a good variety.
- Pretty good petri dish
of humanity right there.
- That was a good answer.
- Thank you.
- That's a great answer.
- [Kelly] Okay.